foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the Utopia
film we're all going to the World's Fair
by Jane schoenbrun special thanks to our
lead sponsor hifa and our virtual
screenings partner Vision media and now
please welcome our guests for this q a
we're all going to the World's Fair
writer director Jane schoenbrun and lead
actor Anna Cobb welcome thank you for
coming today thank you so much for
having us thank you for sharing the
movie
um so we have a lot of members at foam
independent who are aspiring
um filmmakers actors Etc I wondered if
we could just start our conversation by
talking about how each of you
um got into what you're doing now
um Jane do you want to start by talking
about how you became a filmmaker
sure
um well kind of um
relevant to this specific screening uh I
um I worked in film for a long time
before I started making films and um my
first sort of Step into the film
industry
um was at a non-profit called ifp in New
York which is like at one point a sister
organization to film independent very
very similar in terms of the work that I
was doing
um just sort of uh for many years really
thought of myself as somebody who was
sort of put on this Earth to help
artists rather than be an artist and um
a lot of my 20s were spent kind of like
nurturing voices and finding artists who
were doing what I thought of as like
kind of bold and
um personal and maybe like language
pushing things in the film space In
America which um you know because of how
much of a hold of the commercial sort of
landscape has on what gets made and
what's gets seen was um challenging work
as I'm sure Jen you can relate to
um and uh yeah and through that process
just like really learned a lot as a
about myself as a curator and and just
like about the types of movies that I
was passionate about supporting and the
types of artists that I was passionate
about supporting but the um the thing
that was missing for me was um the
confidence to make work
um for my own voice
um and the reason I think that was
missing had a lot to do with um my
gender transition and um sort of working
through
my personal
yeah I think like World's Fair and
really like everything I make
from there on is like about the process
of opening yourself up and looking shame
dead in the eye and and learning to find
your voice as an artist
um in my case uh
sort of young artist in the case of
Casey in the film uh a legitimately
young artist
um yes that's me how about you Anna
Jane you are young I always told Shane I
think that like actually everybody's
Prime is in their uh 30s 40s and 50s so
I look forward to coming into my Prime I
was like Jane you're young you're you're
totally young still and you're and
you're you're actually in your Prime
Jane I hope you understand that so you
better you know take advantage of it
right now
um but uh that was really inspiring what
you said Jane in regards to looking
shame in the eye and I completely agree
um I think any artist can come to
conclusion that you feel this need to
come you know together with humanity and
you want to at least understand it a
little bit more for me I always felt
like I didn't want to ever be
compartmentalized and being told that I
was one thing it's one of my biggest pet
peeves to be told that I have to show up
in the world as one individual thing and
it's one of the reasons why I never
wanted to do one job it's not that other
jobs didn't ever interest me like being
a lawyer you know for example I always
loved being in debate but
um it's just simply I just I don't want
to have to be lawyer Anna being an
actress it gives you this kind of I
suppose like fantasy in this play world
that you can be anything and nobody can
ever say who you are because truly you
are everything at once and if people are
honest with themselves they also are
actors in a way and they have all these
components of themselves and it's
refreshing it's refreshing not to feel
like I have to say like this is just to
me and um it's there's a freedom to that
surely
um so my first question is I saw this
when you played in in Sundance and I
remember when I was uh picking out my
films I saw the title of this and and
I'm a huge history buff and wondered if
it was a documentary about the World's
Fair
it is yeah
I used to uh live in Chicago in the
World's Fair of the 1890s was a big
thing in Chicago that they still have
buildings left over from so but uh I
just thought that the title of this is
so interesting
um and I wanted to ask like what led you
to
I mean pick the title from the phone but
also what what led you to write the
story
um I mean they're kind of two separate
Realms I feel like I'm always searching
for a good title
um
as I you know like as as I work and as I
write and in this case it was definitely
one of the last things to come to me
um
I think with this film especially but
really with like all of my work I I
tried in to both overthink and and and
very purposefully not overthink
um things like uh the the title of the
movie or in the case of The Narrative of
the film like the videos that we see the
name of this role-playing game because
it's one of the things where like if you
come up with something too obvious or
too thought out it starts to feel
writerly and if you come up with
something too random it starts to feel
random
um and uh you know and especially for
like a film about the internet and
that's trying to express through the
language of the film kind of like
algorithm logic which I think of is very
similar to dream logic
um you know the ways in which the next
video that the algorithm chooses for you
maybe doesn't have anything on paper to
do with the video beforehand but like it
it knows you know in the same way that
your subconscious knows uh during a
dream like what what should have happen
next
um and so I think I was like really
while developing this which was a very
long and slow and deliberate process
trying to sort of like let my brain
dream until the right thing popped in so
that's kind of where the World's Fair
came from
um as the name for the the game and then
the title we're all going to the World's
Fair though I had read a book of theory
um
a couple months earlier called imaginary
Futures which was um sort of talking
about
uh the ways in which like throughout the
20th century we sort of imagined you
know our like Jetson style Futures
through
the lens of like the world's there it's
this the book sort of like uses the
World's Fair as like a major
um device to speak about that you know
you go to this place and see the future
on display and um
and how we can learn about our present
by looking at our ideations about the
future
um this was super interesting to me
um and I think
emotionally is in line with what I was
trying to explore about the the the the
present and this moment in the film
um but it really felt right I also
thought um there was a deleted scene in
the movie where um they watch a trailer
a movie trailer for like the bad
Hollywood like sort of um you know like
how they made a Slenderman movie after
the Slender Man was the internet
phenomenon and in the trailer there was
this like evil demon and it's saying
like the World's Fair the World's Fair
and then the like hot teen actor goes no
it's not uh and attacks and that was
sort of like the big Pump Up trailer
moment I thought there was like a funny
pun to be had to so
um that's that
um and in terms of where the story came
from that's a long one
um
the internet loneliness dysphoria
um
yeah all of the usual things
I'm wondering if
either one of you had before the movie
or have since done any of these like
internet challenge games or
Tick Tock challenges or any of the
challenges before you embarked on the
film had you done one before
I'm going to be honest with you I don't
try to go on the internet too much I
feel very angry I don't know there's
something about the internet that puts
me in a bad mood and so I stay far away
if I don't have social media so I I
don't really I didn't know much about it
I had actually do quite a lot of
research so I'm boring in that regard I
don't know much about it we we had to
kind of teach Anna to use a computer in
some ways do you remember oh it's Jade I
know how to use a computer but perhaps
like I don't know like I like like an
ice bucket challenge that's the one I
knew because maybe some school were
doing it but I didn't I was not silly
enough to put ice on my head I didn't
want to do that so but I was definitely
silly enough to do some dumb stuff on
the computer as like a little kid but
that was back in like the late 90s early
2000s before Creepypasta was a thing so
for me it was like um
yeah just like weird internet forums
where I was pretending to be people that
I wasn't
um and
telling stories and yeah like
interacting with strangers and you know
I think a lot of what the film is is is
obliquely sort of ruminating on is yeah
this idea that as a queer kid who hadn't
figured themselves out and as I think an
artist who hadn't figured themselves out
because who has a 14 uh but but
especially as like somebody like who
didn't have many outlets to express like
my weirdness
um in daylight
um
how the internet was a strange and
complicated like kind of uh training
wheels of um of of creativity and
identity play um as a teenager
so so let's talk about Anna
uh enter your phenomenal on this film uh
I think this is your first feature yes
what's uh tell us talk about both Jane
and Anna how did you find each other and
um Anna what made you decide that she
wanted to do this part
oh well I did um I found we're all going
to the World's Fair on a casting website
and I just you know like kind of used to
have been an audition and if the casting
directors or directors like you back
they bring you to their office and
that's what happened I was able to come
back to their Brooklyn office and I
brought my mom along and you know it's
all history from there and when I was
reading the sides in the script I really
appreciated the fact that Casey was
somebody who felt like there was
somebody that didn't get the lights shit
on them before I always think it's much
more interesting to show characters that
are not a recyclable you know over and
over and over again I appreciated the
script in general showing a large span
of humanity is like I think having this
difficult time right now perhaps I'm
speaking for myself but having this own
like out of the body experience not
feeling present within yourself not
feeling like like you have to snap your
fingers repeatedly over your eyes to
feel like you're actually like alive on
this planet that can be a very scary
feeling and it can feel like you're
really distant from things and I'm sure
that that's what leads to a lot of
people having depression and whatnot and
just really attracts me because then
Casey was just kind of this like epitome
of them doing this radical thing and
this kind of even this thing that could
maybe cause her pain like uh plucking
her finger with a needle just to say I'm
here I'm alive it kind of reminds me of
the movie the network it's like I'm a
human being God damn it you know it's
like this like feeling like you're alive
you know and it just really attracted me
not a lot of scripts talk about that I
think it's something that people are
very hush-hush about and it's very
difficult to make this into a film
without it being cheesy or you're trying
to be like yeah like relate to me you
know Jane just effortlessly because she
goes through this and because she felt
it it comes out it like it and I I could
feel it it felt sincere and raw and real
and that's what attracted me so much it
was like a Fatal Attraction I was like
this is great
Jane what so what was it that made you
know that it was Anna who was going to
do this part
I mean I look for a long long long time
yeah on the other end of that casting
call were like many I I many casting
calls many sort of Scouts uh yeah I went
to some dark deep places looking for
someone to play the role
um and I think it was such a specific
role because I knew like like obviously
this was a film that we didn't make for
much money and that was part of the
development process was like all right
I'm going to make a chamber piece
because I want to not you know I think
that I saw so many films in my career at
ifp that were like trying to be
Blockbusters on no money and I really
wanted to make something that was very
restrained and both like incredibly
ambitious emotionally and creatively but
um but very like achievable on a you
know almost non-existent budget
um
and so you know I sort of settled on
this idea of like the internet
as boredom or the internet as like uh
portraiture um you know the ways in
which like including right now we spend
so much of our time just like staring at
ourselves on a box and um and that is
this like invisible idea that structures
increasingly so much of our day-to-day
lives
um
and we indeed we spend like so much of
this film just like staring at Anna um
you know and if if the person that we're
engaging with so much and so deeply like
isn't completely
charismatic complicated transfixing
um just just fascinating in the way that
like a YouTuber that you come across at
3am and you're just like is this person
fucking with me like what is the deal
then
the film wouldn't work you know and and
I kind of had this Instinct that I
wanted to avoid we looked at like actor
actors like people who had kind of come
up as teen actors and
I think you see a lot of folks who are
like too used to like how you're
supposed to be a teen on television or
in a horror movie
um
and then we looked at a lot of um yeah
like a lot of like quote-unquote
non-actors and the problem there was
that um you know you find somebody who
has some kind of Charisma but like this
is a film that like Anna really carries
through like very intensive ambitious
dramatic moments um where like a lot is
resting on her abilities and a lot most
non-actors like can't just switch on
that kind of Charisma
um and so I was just looking for for
months
um and like basically full-time
searching and was like I'm not making
this movie until we find somebody who's
like
Jennifer Lawrence and Winter's Bone like
you know like find uh find a star and uh
and then Anna's tape came in and it was
or at first I guess I saw just down his
picture and and I was really struck by
like the the head shot Anna was using
was like this kind of like that Eerie
bathroom selfie that I was just like oh
that's different
um and uh
and there's just something very Casey
asked in it
um and then Anna's tape came in and it
was just like immediately clear to
everyone on the team that this was like
the needle in the haystack
um the you know the what whatever
metaphor like out of all of the people
that we had spent months looking for it
was like all of that was to find Anna
all of that was to find this person who
not only like understood and fit the
role so perfectly but could like elevate
it into
um you know like a human being and and
so much of the process of making the
film with Anna who is just like the
greatest collaborator of all time so
brave and so generous and and so sort of
um yeah just collaborative
um it was so much of it was like not
just like fitting Anna into the
character but like kind of creating and
evolving the character around Anna um
and I just yeah it was a lot of work and
it was worth it
yeah it was thank you it was worth it
I I
wholeheartedly agree totally worth it
um
so you have some
um some well big names in the Indie
worlds uh working with you on this film
like Daniel Carbone uh Matthew pizza and
David Lowry uh Anthony is a doc
filmmaker
um did you know all these filmmakers
before and um
uh can you talk about your collaboration
with uh like Daniel in particular as
your DP
yeah so I met Dan and Matt who um are
both EPS on the film and really helped
us like um
figure out how to make a movie like
adults make movies
um like when Anna talked about going to
our production office that was like uh
Dan and Matt and their producing partner
Zach's office and the Flies Collective
um
I knew them because I had actually
programmed Dan's first film back when I
was at ifp about 10 years earlier a film
A Beautiful film called hide your
smiling faces that was very fluential on
looking at like what people were doing
in the Indie space that felt like the
kind of thing that I would want to do in
that space and I think I actually did I
make you watch that movie and I think I
made you watch that movie right it was
beautiful totally unique yeah totally
just like have always felt a real
kinship to Dan's work and um Dan is also
just like an incredible visual artist
and um and such a generous collaborator
and
yeah I've been very nervously asked him
if he would be down to shoot the film
and uh and
having his I really think he was it's
like him Anna I think Alex who did the
score for the movie are like three
artists who
completely transformed the film
in the best possible way that like a
great creative collaborator will where
you know you invite somebody in who
is sort of like a fellow traveler
creatively but who can do something that
you could never in a million years and
Dan Dan brought like an aesthetic at a
gaze to the film that um I think is just
just so so rich and important to the
movie
um David Lowry yeah I knew
I programmed a script that he had
written uh I guess ain't the body Saints
um uh before that that film came out and
um
David is at the time he was living in
Austin Texas or Dallas and he um
I really like looked up to David a lot
because he was the kind of filmmaker who
even while his career was starting to
Blossom was like assistant camera
shooting his friends films down there
and there there were like a few years
there where he every film that came out
of Texas he had some role in even if
that role was like uh assistant editor
or something and um
that kind of like generosity and also
like the space that he's carved out for
himself as somebody making incredibly
ambitious films but also films that feel
personal and surprising consistently was
definitely like uh yeah he was
definitely like a mentor slash um person
who I was like there are many American
filmmakers who I can look at and and say
like especially like young American
filmmakers I want that kind of career
but David's is David's is definitely one
that I admire a lot
um and I basically just asked him if
he'd put his name on the film because
that helps when you're a small movie
without big celebrities in it um and he
was like yeah and uh he's a sweetie
and Theo Anthony I knew yeah through
Baltimore friends
and um
who would look good slapping themselves
on a treadmill and I was like he has not
only uh
he's also super hot so um we'll take
your shirt off for us did you just call
or text him and say hey can you slap
yourself while you're running on a
treadmill for me uh luckily um Abby uh
my lovely casting director who used to
you used to live with Theo uh okay I
believe she made the uh the actual um
will you slap yourself ask
Ed
I'm lucky in that I feel like I know a
lot of people who would say yes to that
slap themselves on a treadmill if I ever
need it
um that's fantastic it's so nice to hear
you know when Andy filmmakers are have
like you know good Indie filmmaker Karma
and want to help other filmmakers out
it's uh that's very heartening I feel
like we've had a lot of film independent
fellows like that too who are well we
have a lot of them we ask a lot of them
to Mentor up-and-coming filmmakers as
well and it's nice when people give
their time to do that
a community of filmmakers and artists
that that I that I collaborate with it's
like yeah I'm very collaborative as an
artist I think I
yeah it's because I kind of like came up
as a fan and and put away my own work
for so long that like it I still get
giddy about collaborating with people
who who I admire
um what so what do the two of you have
coming up Jane I think you have are you
at work on another feature shooting
another feature or is it finished
Anna and I are both killing it we're
both like like
many projects
I shot a new film this summer for a24
which was an amazing experience
um
and totally different than World's Fair
because
um yeah bigger budget bigger different
system that you're working within
um and trying to make something like
just as strange and personal and and
surprising
um
and it was an amazing experience
um it's called I saw the TV glow
um
Stars Justice Smith and Bridget Lundy
Payne and Lindsey Jordan from snail mail
and Phoebe Bridger shows up in it and
Fred Durst is in it from Limp Biscuit
Daniel deadweiler is in it it's pretty
wild it's a weird one
um I'm really proud of her do you have
any idea when it's going to come out
what's is that more like 2023 I think
we're talking about 2023
um I'm deep in the edit and uh I'm
really really having fun with it
um and yeah trying to just keep making
things
it often feels like threading a needle
especially like as budgets grow to
make things that are personal and
vulnerable and um and that like feel
like they need to come out I think I
always start from a space of like
what can I try to express that feels
like very very
personal but also like hidden like what
what can I put on the screen that like
well maybe articulate something that
will mean something to somebody else and
um
and with the first two films I'm like
really proud of that like Anna was
saying like kind of vulnerable process
and um
pitching a TV show and yeah I like want
to try to do that on bigger levels but
it's it's definitely a dance
yeah
and Anna can be seen on screens all over
the country this winter well perhaps yes
I suppose it's November 23rd I believe
bones and all by local guadinos gonna
come I got to partake in this film and
then also director Catherine Lombardi uh
the head of John the Baptist so I did
that
um both last year and this year so look
forward to it I suppose and I was I'm
very lucky just to partake in any
production and I really appreciate it
and um yes perhaps I will see see in the
future of my writing well like I'll hit
a dart and I'll hit the bullseye we'll
see we'll see
are you a writer as well Anna I am a
writer I don't know if I can consider
myself a writer until I get some
no matter you're a writer I okay I'm a
writer but like I may be in my own
little headspace I'm a writer but let's
see let's see if it goes out properly
we'll see I think it will I manage them
a very talented writer uh who would tell
us epic epic tales that she had written
on such thank you thank you yeah I it
was actually really nice they listened
to my stories so you know Jane I
actually completed one already
yeah I'll send it I'll send it
kind of moved to Florida which is a real
heartbreak for those of us in New York I
want Anna to come back to New York so we
can cook her dinner and and hang out
yeah
I'm in Florida for a reason I'm very
happy down here Jane you ought to come
down here and it's cold down to Florida
I'm going to Florida come down to
Florida and have some like good s'mores
and and let's just let's just relax you
know we're gonna have some s'mores yeah
I know exactly what to say s'mores
I just
thank you so much you two for talking to
me I love it when I get to interview
people that love each other so much and
yeah I need each other's lives and it
was it was the best collaboration and I
can't wait for the next one I can feel
that and it's really special and I'm
really happy
um so congratulations to the both of you
on this film and I'm looking forward
forward to your new films coming out and
I hope when your new things come out
I'll get to talk to you again
yeah yeah and I I hope to talk to you
again and thank you so much I appreciate
all your time consideration you're so
kind and this is really lovely thank you
thank you
independent for supporting weird little
films like ours
[Music]